hello everyone and welcome to a
wonderful game from yesterday's
Champions Chester AI copy this Magnus
Carlson versus yaniponishi as usual they
played Four rapid games and we are going
to show a game three the game that
decided the match but we're also going
to show game two uh because a really
weird thing happening game two so let's
dive straight into it is Magnus Carlsen
versus Yani polishi two old rivals uh
from the World Church championship match
uh let's check it out so Magnus uh opens
with Pawn to E4 and pawn to E5 we have
Knight to F3 Knight to F6 nipple going
for the Battle of defense or the Russian
defense and Knight captures on E5 this
is the classical variation and the best
way to tackle this we have the 692 F3
and not Knight captures on e4 and there
are many ways you could treat this uh
the main line is of course spawn to D4
this is known as the classical attack
but I always like to mention Knight the
C3 because it almost always works like
I've even seen this happen in a
classical game uh where I was it was a
team in event I don't remember which
event it was but a teammate of mine
playing Knight to C3 uh sorry no his
opponent played Knight to C3 my teammate
captured and after d captures and C3 my
teammates played Bishop to G4 which
seems like a good move but it's really
not in this position uh because after H3
what is the bishop to do if you capture
the Knight then you obviously don't have
the bishop parent if you go back then
Queen to D5 connect with the bishop
ended the B7 pawn and uh well there's
really nothing you have if you want to
avoid losing material you have to give
up the bishop Queen captures and now you
have a dream position with white already
uh with move nine your Bishops can be
developed in natural Square so you can
Castle occupy the D1 and D1 square with
your Rooks so it's uh something you
would expect to see in a game 150 years
ago but okay these are of course Magnus
and nipple Pawn to D for the classical
attack with Pawn to D5 and Bishop to D3
with Bishop to D6 and now both players
Castle so castles castles and pawn to C4
uh the Marshall variation we have Pawn
to C6 and now Mainline is Knight to C3
but Rook D1 also extremely popular uh
Bishop to F5 you have to defend the
Knight here and Knight the C3 now just
piling up on the Knight end also on that
Central D5 Pawn so mag nipple trades
here we have Knight captures B captors
and Bishop captures and D3 Queen
captures and the D captures and C4 now
Queen captures and Knight to D7 so all
been played before uh nothing new really
happening here Queen to B3 moving the
queen so you can get the pawn to C4
because uh well it's just better also
you do it with Tempo and you might
developed the bishop to this diagonal uh
where it will be incredibly strong so
Queen to C7 defends the pawn Here pawn
to C4 and now Rook after E8 threatening
to capture on E1 uh G3 there is a game
where uh well not one game many games
where Bishop to BT was played but Nepal
plays Pawn to G3 first and it is now
only as of move 16 that we have a
completely new game so okay Ponto B6 by
Magnus and the bishop to B2 now nicely
putting the bishop and this long
diagonal and nepo defense will Bishop to
f8 now the
uh this bishop will not uh be that
problematic we have a pawn to A4 and
pawn to A6 with King to G2 and pawn to
H6 just making useful moves with Rook
captures and E8 Rook capture 78 and now
Basha back to C1 the bishop no longer
that useful in this diagonal Magnus that
wants to shift it over to this diagonal
and put pressure on the black queen so
Bishop to C1 we have rooked the B8 for
the moment it doesn't really do all that
much because Bishop to D6 would just be
very strong nipple will uh definitely
welcome the exchange of the dark Square
Bishops uh Queen to C2 and now Rook back
to E8 with Pawn to A5 trying to open up
the position here B5 and now C captures
on B5 we have a capture some B5 and
Bishop to B Bishop to F4 attacking the
queen here so both Magnus and nipple
have a past Pawn now we have Bishop to
D6 and the Magnus straight captors
captures and Ponte Asics his past pass
Pawn is already on the sixth rank Rook
to A8 and now Ponte 7 but how are you
defending the pawn after Queen to C7
that is the real question here well
Magnus says you don't really have to
Queen to C7 and now Rook to A6 now he
wants to trade this Pawn for this Pawn
to make this Pawn weaker and then
hopefully eliminate both of them and you
could play something like Pawn to C5
nipple goes for Knight to f8 instead we
have Queen to C5 and now Knight to E6
attacking the queen here Rook captures
attacks the queen and now Queen to B7
Nepal going for some tricks here as now
uh the queen is x-raying the king and G2
if you can get something like Knight to
G5 in if the Rook moves could be very
nasty and also you are just supporting
that past B Pawn so Queen to B6 of
course Magnus offers the queen trade
Rook captures an A7 and now even Pawn to
D5 we have Knight to f8 and now Queen to
C5 and here with Knight the G6 nipple is
uh still in the game but he played
Knight to D7 attacking magnus's Queen
and here Magnus is just dead as sorry
Snapple is just dead lost and it's
actually a very basic idea very
Elementary principle which you should
know as it often happens in everyone's
games that as it does here in a Magnus
nipple game unbelievable but it's true
uh I would ask you to pause the video
but I'm sure you guys already see it
it's not
very tricky but if you defend well and
nepo does defend well you have to see
much much further so of course it's a
rook to see it check King to H7 and now
Queen deceit you check forcing the only
move uh G6 you could also play F5 but
that really makes no sense so G6 and now
once you've opened up this diagonal of
course you will play Queen to C3 now how
do you stop Checkmate well Knight to F6
nipple defends with uh with tactics
because now if Queen captures then The
Rook is left undefended so Pawn to D6
and now look at this point to B4 and now
the incredible winning move what do you
think it is I'm sure you guys already
have spotted it Queen to C7 the only
move but it gets the job done now the
problem is you can't really trade Queens
if you trade Queens then just grow
captures attacks the rook and the F7
pawn and if the Rook moves doesn't
really matter you will simply play Rook
captures here and after King to G8 you
will just capture the knight uh you
can't really Advance the pawn doesn't
really do anything because D7 is just
winning uh so you know you're up a piece
it doesn't really make sense so after
Queen to C7 nepo tried Pawn to G5 but
now Queen capture some B7 Rook captures
and Rook to C7 pretty much with the with
the same idea Rook to B5 Rook captures
and F7 check King to G6 and now even
Pawn to D7 and there's really not much
you can try here nepo tried Rook to D5
and it's a it's a very clever defense
because there's only one way to win this
for Magnus uh
I'm pretty sure you guys see it uh so
I'm not gonna make this a pause the
video moment but of course the move is
night the E5 with check it checks the
king defends the rook and tries to
misplace The Rook away from the D file
so you can Queen your d-pawn so of
course you cannot capture uh King to D5
was played a king to F5 was played and
now another tricky move Knight to G4
this is a beautiful beautiful
uh knight move uh uh because there
there's no way out of it uh uh Rook
captures on F6 is being threatened this
will end in Checkmate so you have to
capture but if you capture it then comes
Rook captures and F6 and it seems like
you're in time but you cannot touch this
Pawn if you touch this Pawn then of
course spawn to F3 check and you're
getting checkmated King to H5 G4 G for
checking to H4 and now Rook captures and
H6 will be Checkmate so after Rook
captures an F6 King to H5 was played but
now Pawn to H3 and he was in this
position on move 47 that Yani promen
should resigned the game as there is
nothing more to be done here G4 check
followed by a rook captures and H6 will
be Checkmate and there's no way to avoid
this and if you play G4 which doesn't
give your king the G5 Square then you
fall victim to Rook to F5 check
beautiful uh sacrifice that moves the
Rook away from the D file uh Rook
captures and now of course the d8 queen
or you can even capture with check first
and then after King captures then bring
your queen into the game and now it's a
queen against The Rook of is completely
winning but nepo did not wait for this
after he saw H3 of course he knew what
was coming and he resigned the game so
game one and game two ended in a draw
game 3 Was Won by Magnus Ending game for
nepo did have the white pieces and he
had a great initiative he could have
done something but in the game in the
end the
uh game uh result to a to a draw uh but
the the craziest moment actually
happened in the game two which I'm going
to show you now uh uh maybe I should
show the entire game or maybe just the
position I'm gonna show the entire game
but just the position in question
because it also uh a lot of fun so never
played Ponte four magnets went for his
usual Sicilian Knight F3 D6 nipple win
for the uh Canal attack Knights to D7
Nepal Castle uh and now Pawn to A6
attacking the Knight Bishop Bishop to E2
and now Knight G2 F6 spawn to D3 Pawn to
E6 and pawn to a for Pawn to B6 and now
there are some games where Knight A3 was
played C4 is unknown move but never
plays Knight after D2 with a very tricky
idea and it's now as of move a that we
have a completely new game so now he
wants to put the bishop on F3 and put
pressure on this long diagonal so okay
Bishop D7 by Magnus spawn to F4 and now
castles with Bishop to F3 uh and uh of
course Magnus counters it with Bishop to
B7 night not night the C3 haunted D5 and
now Pawn to G4 and nipple really wants
to get the most out of his game with the
white pieces Knight to B8 onto G5 and
now Knights the E8 for the moment uh
retrieving uh the knights to the back
rank E Capture Sun D5 e captures and
Bishop to G2 with Knight to C7 now the
Knight can come to E6 and here Knight
the C for re-maneuvering the Knight with
the tactics as the Bushman B7 would hang
if you capture the Knight don't Knight
the C6 and now Knight captures and B6
Magnus even gives up this Pawn Rook to
B8 now Knight B captures on D5 so nepo
is um
uh definitely better here but he will
have to he will have to prove it as
Magnus does have some compensation for
the sacrifice material Knight captures
on the E5 Knight captures and now
Knights the D4 threatening to pick up
the Knight here and while you could
capture an E7 uh nipple decides to play
C4 and defend the Knight with Bishop to
D6 so you don't have this tension on E7
Bishop to E3 and now Knight to five
Magnus is now down two pawns and he does
not want to trade he wants activity for
his pieces Bishop to D2 and now of
course the B2 Pawn is undefended so
Magnus will give up the strong Bishop
captures Bishop captures and now Rook
captures and beat you and here
objectively nippo is still better but uh
Magnus has uh sort of the initiative and
nipple already advanced the Pawns in
front of his King to F4 and G5 so he has
to be very very careful and uh well
careful he was not he played Bishop to
C3 and here Magnus actually has a forced
Checkmate in five feel free to pause the
video and try to spot it while I give
you a couple of seconds
foreign
for those of you who are able to do it
congratulations on finding a move that
Magnus couldn't find and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show it
is Queen captures and G5 a spectacular
Queen sacrifice we can even do it in
slow motion there you have it uh Magnus
played Knight to E3 which is the second
strongest move recommended by the engine
but not the strongest one luckily you
guys are here to find the strongest one
Queen capture Sun G5 and now it doesn't
matter what black does if you capture
the queen it's actually just a mating
two Bishop captures an H2 check King to
H1 and now Knights the g3s Checkmate as
The Rook controls the entire second Rank
and the bishop covers the G1 square and
if you don't accept the queen sacrifice
well there's just uh nothing for you to
do if you go King to H1 still Knights
the G3 check and once you capture Queen
to H6 check and now the queen Rook combo
is absolutely devastating you have to
give up the queen For No Good Reason
after King to G1 you will deliver a nice
Checkmate here so that was in the
position but Magnus missed it and uh he
did play the second strongest but after
a few more moves they just settle for a
repetition here with this queen T4 Queen
C7 Queen E5 Queen D7 24 Queen Seven uh
so yeah uh that's uh that's what
happened but uh here after this bishop
the C3 move it's absolutely incredible
that magnus's spidey sense did not go
off here uh everyone was expecting Queen
G5 to happen like instantly but you just
don't expect it you just don't expect it
in a position like this because you you
you you didn't plan it you didn't uh uh
you know if played Bishop capture some
B2 with the idea that Bishop to C3 is of
course a possibility but then he says
okay but Queen G5 just demolishes it
then it would happen but he didn't see
it he went for Knight E3 which is
perfectly fine it just doesn't enter the
game spectacularly uh so yeah this one
ended in a draw this is the second game
third one Magnus one a fourth one ended
in a draw and that means the Magnus wins
the semi-final match against Yani
pondichi and he goes into the finals
where he will face none other than
Maxine bashiella grav there you have it
it's the winners final but remember it
is not the Grand Final uh we we still
have to see the loser semi-final then
the losers final and then whoever wins
the final will face uh the winner of the
losers final in the Grand Final as it uh
as it usually happens uh so yeah that's
the game hope you guys enjoyed it and a
big congratulations if you found Queen
characters on G5 instead of Knight D3
you are truly an amazing player I would
like to thank helge matric J1 southern
girls
festival.org.gg 15 to 21st of October
2023 bullet just thriller.com and eBay
numismatics for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on you wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the Chess World so thank you all I will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day and remember you still have
a chance at playing alireza firoza first
link in the description below explains
how and why see you soon